trop de blabla je suis passé
complètement à côté parce que j'achète
en bagnole j'avais 14 ans déjà 88
j'avais 14 ans que j'étais là je
conduisais ma petite Fiat droit de
blague
c'est pas bon dans les dates normales
c'est un pays de bandit quoi
les lois sont un petit peu plus jeunes
conduite
accompagnées
je suis passé complètement à côté du
fait que c'est une chanson contre la
violence cette femme ben oui parce qu'en
fait à l'époque à l'époque donc j'étais
avec un homme et une foutait sur la
gueule mais moi en tant que Monsieur
mais tu sais quand moi quand tu me tapes
je te tape si tu veux pas mais donc
j'avais pas l'impression que c'est
d'être une victime de violence mais bon
je me suis retrouvé quand même avec des
bleus des cocards des côtes des cheveux
et vous portez pas plein de trucs pas du
tout moi ce qu'on faisait en faisait des
traquenards on a tendance chez lui on va
voilà quoi c'est ça
tu l'attends en bas de chez lui pour
leur frapper bien sûr
même une fois mes parents mon père et
mon oncle sont venus et non non le nom
attendu pour le raisonner le gars
n'était pas raisonnable donc non c'est
incroyable mais on régler ça entre nous
quoi il y avait pas de
alors il est encore vivant bien sûr
tu as été frappé par des hommes pas un
seul
très touchant tu m'as dit ta sœur
non j'ai pas dit qu'elle en était mort
je dis que d'après moi enfin d'après moi
c'est pas d'après moi elle est elle a
quitté cet homme elles sont déjà mermise
et elle est décédée
ah oui terriblement c'est c'est en
écrivant ce texte enfin c'est parce que
je me suis rendu compte à cette époque
là que moi j'étais victime de violent
que ma petite sœur aussi que j'avais des
copines et moi j'étais là trop de blabla
enfin j'avais envie de leur dire mais
elle est tous vous faire bien sûr
tu vois j'ai pas une question madame
princesse c'est que
vous parlez de tout sans aucun tabou et
c'est super vous dites vous dites
notamment il y a un pamphlet qui est
sorti à manifeste dans lequel il a fait
une Richard dans lequel il y a vous et
tout ça et vous dites c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui actrice en France qu'on
le veuille ou non cité noir témoin payé
et vous aviez dit sur Camping Paradis et
franchement j'ai Jean-Luc Jean-Luc
Azoulay il vous en veux pas te parler il
m'a dit il y a aucun souci oui sur
Camping Paradis salut les années passées
moi on m'écrivez de textes je trouvais
pas de place et j’étais l'actrice la
moins payée à ce nom c'est vrai que
j'étais actrice la moins payée bon alors
mais je pense que c'est parce que
j'avais un mauvais agent qui avait mal
négocié
alors en plus tu vois c'était dans
l'émission à l'époque la mesure de cette
petite c'est celui qui te tire les vers
du nez que tu n'as pas tu vois bon bref
et en fait j'avais fait quand même une
explique des explicative pour dire
pourquoi et tout et que je me sens mais
je leur ai dit je veux dire je suis allé
me plaindre c'est un truc qui était
interne moi j'en parle parce que j'ai
une grande gueule et je ferais des fois
mieux de la fermer mais j'en ai parlé
comme ça et ça a été accolé comme si
c'était parce que j'étais noir que
j'étais moi regardez vous dites dans les
livres noirs n'est pas un métier dans
lequel il y a Firmin Richard qui a fait
la crise première étoile qui s'apparent
vous euh
pardon il y a plein d'actrices noires et
faire une Richard qui a jouécane dans la
crise pardon première étoile dit j'étais
l'actrice la moins payée parce que je
suis noir elle raconte ça pour huit
femmes elle dit
vous avez soutenu aux dernières
élections Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous dites
que c'était nécessaire alors on va en
parler aujourd'hui justement vous vous
en parler avec lui à vous vous non je
n'en parlais pas je suis je suis très
proche de Raquel Garrido et de Alexandre
qui habite mon quartier avec près de
chez moi donc voilà mais je leur ai
toujours dit moi je connais Jean-Luc pas
personnellement mais en tous les cas je
le suis depuis qu'il est au Front de
gauche parce que le maire de ma commune
on trahi était son direct c'était pour
t'arranger pour te garer quoi
il se trouve que c'est vrai que je le
vois depuis longtemps et je trouve que
il est juste il est juste ok alors j'ai
une question de poser il y a ce qu'il a
dit sur les retraites c'était très
intéressant à te poser s'il te plaît
quand tu vois qu'aujourd'hui c'est parce
que jamais qu'on soit cohérent quand tu
vois qu'aujourd'hui il est arrivé un peu
en despote on nous a République c'est
moi et qu'aujourd'hui il défend son
député qui a giflé sa femme et tu t'es
battu contre la violence aux femmes
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui encore tu dirais
je soutiens Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais
alors déjà moi je trouve que mettre les
histoires personnelles au sein il agit
une femme il a gif
un moment très difficile très clé pour
moi parce que c'était des élections
présidentielles d'accord il fallait
qu'on dégage Macron on a pas réussi et
regarde on en est aujourd'hui s'il est
extra de droit de passer au prochain des
élections vous faites quoi ben je combat
moi je suis une grande vous quitter la
France mais pourquoi je quitte la France
je suis française
dis donc princesse je t'adore princesse
je t'aime chérie mais tu peux pas me
dire ça princesse
noire je suis une femme non bien sûr
mais je suis en france je suis né en
France je suis française j'ai choisi en
plus parce que comme je suis né de
parents camerounais j'ai choisi d'être
nationale d'avoir la nationalité
française tu peux pas me dire si si je
si l'extrême droite moi je lutte je
lutte je continue je ne peux pas me
tirer en plus au moment où parce que
j'ai vraiment interview vous avez dit
moi je prends le pognon et puis quand
j'en ai marre je pars en Afrique
déjà tu sais pourquoi j'irai pas en
Afrique parce que d'abord je pense que
les Africains enfin en tous les cas au
Cameroun ils ont pas besoin ils sont
très très bien voilà ils ont toutes
l'énergie vitale pour moi je suis hyper
bien sûr et je vais d'ailleurs parce que
j'ai perdu mon papa il y a pas longtemps
prêt à son âme je vais voir mes cousines
je vais rendre visite à ma famille je
suis très contente d'y aller mais
non je ne bouge pas alors mon coeur
d'amour mon cœur d'amour bébé d'amour
une femme paradoxal c'est ce que j'aime
vous dites la chanson MMA qui a été
reprise pour troubleda vous vous l'avez
dit donc c'est très bien bravo vous
rapporte 60000 € par mois alors ça aussi
je reviens là-dessus parce que contexte
voilà c'est ça exactement
que j'aime énormément parce que c'est
quand même lui qui m'a lancé dans ce
dans le milieu télévisuel il me pose la
question princesse
et moi je joue le jeu je dis 60000 parce
que je veux pas qu'il descend trop bas
quand même
mais si tu un jour je t'emmène mes
fiches d'impôts mais c'est tellement pas
ça c'est tellement pas et en plus
aujourd'hui on voit bien que bah ils
prennent juste eux-mêmes ah bon ben
voilà là où je t’amène sur un paradoxe
vous faites la Ferme célébrité qui
pardon a vraiment une mauvaise image
pour laisser brider surtout que vous
êtes une célébrité et que ça descendez
pas pour vous et vous allez refuser ma
singer et Danse avec les stars pourquoi
ah non alors Danse avec les stars j'ai
fait le casting et d'ailleurs mon agent
qui m'avait fait faire le casting est là
tu fais des trucs tu danses pendant 5h
et tout tu signes des précontre avec toi
bon réduit le casting le la semaine
enfin l'année d'après il m'appelle je
dis un casting il me dit oui ben non je
le fais pas
le casting tu vois non c'est pas mon
petit caractère
tu étais pas bien
bah écoute alors au moment où ils m'ont
proposé j'étais je sortais mon album
j'ai c'était pas le moment alors s'il me
le propose peut-être tu vois moi c'est
le moment le moment présent je le vis à
fond là je suis en promo de mon album et
dernière merci de m'inviter
l'écouter en stream je suis pas une
scène je veux pas le paradis et cetera
tu vois je suis voilà mais je suis pas
je suis pas contre tout ce qui est
populaire et tout ce qui est moi l'image
c'est moi tu vois c'est moi
qui a donné ça rapportait 30 000 € à une
association pour soutenir l'Afrique du
Sud et qui était absolument c'est
important de dire
donc je ne regrette rien est-ce que je
peux dire aussi un petit mot sur vos
enfants parce que vous parlez de tout et
quand je dis que vous avez une vie de
femme battante j'adore ça vous allez
toujours l'avant et à la pub mais je
m'en fous je me plains pas vous avez un
fils qui est pas schizophrène dans des
schizoïdes psychotique psychotique
pardon c'est-à-dire qu'il est dans un
hôpital non pas du tout ça veut dire que
il était il a il a fait des séjours mais
il est très voilà c'est lui il est super
beau il est adorable c'est mon fils que
j'aime il a il a une super vie il est
autonome il a son taf il a son appart et
tout on peut vivre avec une maladie au
début c'était difficile j'imagine parce
que quand tu connais pas c'est toujours
dur et tu n'as pas envie de voir ton
enfant souffrir voilà il y a aucun
moment tu t'es dit euh je me suis fait
battre par mon mec j'ai un enfant qui
est malade j'ai waouh ça ça change un
peu quand même mais non pas du tout
parce que moi je suis bénie tu es fou ou
quoi moi je suis béni parce que tu sais
si tu veux ce que je dis pourquoi parce
que
moi je suis créé je suis croyante et je
dis que Dieu ne t'envoie les épreuves
que ce que si tu peux les supporter donc
moi si mon envoi des costauds comme ça
voilà c'est bon je supporte pas trop moi
donc si tu peux me lâcher un petit peu
c'était la conclusion je vous adore vous
parlez de tout vous êtes une femme
battant vous êtes une femme positive
quand on voit des gens comme vous on
repart on est boosté bah j'espère mais
en fait moi c'est je pense que l'artiste
c'est son rôle après chaque chacun sa
son précarité mais moi mon rôle moi ce
que j'aime c'est l'enthousiasme il y a
que ça j'ai que ça à vendre je n'ai que
ça non mais c'est ouf
tu as rien mais si j'ai des chirurgien
non j'ai trop peur il y a quelqu'un
dedans
elle fait ma fille en tous les cas album
je suis pas une sainte on a mis les
dates il faut y aller et je te jure
c'est j'ai adoré te rencontrer je te
fais des gros gros bisous